turns out Big Bird maybe the best
substitute teacher after all a new study
from professors at the University of
Maryland and Wellesley College found
that watching Sesame Street delivers
educational benefits as effective as
preschool by watching the program
children are more likely to state the
appropriate grade level for their age
especially for those in disadvantaged
areas the study found that children in
areas where the Sesame Street broadcast
was received saw a 14% drop in their
likelihood of being behind in school
boys and african-american boys in
particular saw a pronounced effect the
researchers say it was probably from
Sesame Street's focused on an academic
curriculum of reading and math that
appear to have helped children prepare
for school Alex Steele who has a pre pre
pre preschooler at home is taking notes
and you would you let your daughter
watch Sesame Street after reading this
article quite frankly I kind of want to
I'm thinking should we start doing that
like one one hour of Sesame Street a
week is she too young for that
because that was so striking to me about
this article but the other sort of study
that came out was it is it relevant now
and they couldn't answer that was really
from a test group back in the 70s where
you were able to have a portion of the
population that didn't even have access
to it and you had a portion that was it
was really easy to track them now it's
much more difficult and of course the
programming options were much different
in the 70s and the early seventies a
third of all American toddlers watched
Sesame Street I don't know what the
proportion is now but I doubt it's
anything like one right and we don't
know and that's part of the issue it
also raises the question well if you can
get a really good education from Sesame
Street do you actually need preschool
that was sort of what the issue was
coming out of it the answer was yes
because you're teaching them about
emotional development you're teaching
them how to interact with their people
and it's also a resource for parents as
well in a way that Sesame Street is not
but it definitely got me thinking I was
like should I let my daughter watch
Sesame Street now at eight months I'm a
big fan of Sesame Street there showed
the program on TV not so much a fan of
Sesame Place which is the amusement park
that developed around the show nothing
educational about that as far as I could
tell when I went there this supposed to
be I get dragged into an amusement park
and they're like let's teach you about
know that Elmo does appear on station
reportedly teaches you something but
mostly about how loud screaming children
can be truth it was a very interesting
study nonetheless absolutely are